Leanback provides a set of pre-built
widgets that are specially designed to
help you create an Android TV app.
Particularly, but not exclusively
one that's designed to browse and
play media.
This UI that you see here was
created entirely with Leanback.
All we have to do is provide
the assets like images and
instruct Leanback how
we want them laid out.
We also get all of this
smooth animation for free.
Let's talk briefly about
the principal widgets.
Everything on the screen that you
see here is the browse fragment.
It provides our basic layout.
On the left, you can see
a bunch of column headers, and
on the right you can see rows.
Conceptually and behind the scenes, the
browse fragment is composed of a headers
fragment on the left and
a rows fragment on the right.
This is only important to know
because the headers fragment can be
hidden if you'd like.
And of course, each header is
tied to its own individual row.
Beyond layout, browse fragment does
way more for us behind the scenes, and
it actually contains the code for
all of these animations as well as for
very efficient display of
large lists and media items.
This is a card, and cards are a very
important part of the Leanback library.
A card constitutes a small view.
In the media browser application,
you might use cards like this
to display songs and movies.
If we select a card,
we'll see the details fragment.
It's useful for, you guess it
showing more details about a card.
In addition to details about a card,
the details fragment contains actions.
Like watching a trailer or
buying or renting a movie.
And if you scroll down,
to see a row of related videos.
If we decide to watch a trailer,
we'll see the playback overlay fragment.
Not surprisingly, this provides
controls for playing back media.
Let's try it out.
[SOUND] You'll notice that
after about five seconds,
the UI will fade away so
the content is front and center.
In addition to playback controls,
you can add custom buttons
to the overlay fragment.
For instance, to like or dislike media.
The basic strategy for
building an app with Leanback
is to wrap your media library, so it can
be displayed as a series of headers and
cards on the browse fragment.
We'll see how this works in
code in the next lesson, but
first let's see how it works by design.
Leanback follows the model view
presenter design pattern and
if you're not familiar with them, a
design pattern is just a high level way
of describing how code is structured.
There are three pieces to start, and
the good news is that they
pretty much all just sit there.
By that I mean, they don't
take any actions on their own.
First, we have a model.
A model is just a fancy word for
a database, or a content provider, or
however you decided to organize and
store your data.
In this case,
let's say we have a database of movies.
Each individual movie in the database
might have a text field for
the title and a bitmap for
the box artwork.
You can see a single movie
here displayed on this view.
And a view is just a regular Android
view that's used to display some data.
Here, let's say we use an image card
view that's included with Leanback.
On your UI,
you create one of these views for
each movie you'd like to display.
Now, a presenter's job is to take an
item from the model, say, a movie, and
map it to the view.
Basically, all the presenter does is
say the title should go here, and
the box artwork should go here.
Simple, right?
Now as I said at runtime,
all these pieces just hang out.
They're orchestrated by another
class called an ObjectAdapter.
An ObjectAdapter has two jobs.
One, it collects item from the model,
and two it creates a view for each item.
In order to create that
view it uses the presenter.
In our application code,
we create an object adapter and
give it a presenter in its constructor.
Next, we add items from our
model to the ObjectAdapter
that we'd like to be displayed.
At runtime, Leanback uses our
object adapter to create views for
our items on its fragments.
In the next lesson, we'll see
how these concepts work in code.